سياسيا قلت جورنال نقلا عن مستشار رئاسي
اوكراني رفيع ودبلوماسيين اوروبيين قالت
ان اوكرانيا وحلفائها يخططون لعقد قمه
لزعماء العالم من شانها استبعاد روسيا
بهدف حشد الدعم لشروطكيه لنهايه الحرب
ووفق صحيفه فان خطه القمه تحظى بدعم قوي
من القاده الاوروبيين وان فرنسا والدنمارك
والسويد عرضت باستضافتها كما ان القاده
الاوروبيين بمن فيهما الرئيس الفرنسي
يضغطونه من اجل مشاركه الدول التي انحازت
الى روسيا او رفضت اتخاذ موقف بشان الحرب
ونقلت عن دبلوماسيين اوروبيين
طلب في وقت مبكر من هذا العام من الرئيس
الفرنسي مساعدته في التواصل الدولي مع
قاده
كرئيس الصيني بحسب الصحيفه دائما فان هناك
مساعيا مع كير لاعاده صياغه خطه السلام
الاوكرانيه من 10 نقاط بطرق تجعلها اكثر
قبولا للقوى العالميه الاخرى كالهند
والبرازيل والسعوديه والصين